[Music]
my name is sharon alvarez
i am the icu manager at ascension st
thomas midtown in nashville tennessee
my name is dr christopher brown and i am
a hospitalist for the
university of kansas health system in
kansas city kansas
this is one of our units that we like to
cohort
our patients
[Music]
my name is petty keller i'm a registered
nurse at buffalo general in buffalo new
york
just finished working 12 and a half hour
night shift
i took my masks off and i call these my
warm arcs
hi my name is tony neal i'm a patient
service specialist
in the department of mental health for
baylor scott in white
what position do you play water boy
whatever they need
my name is belinda spahn i'm part of the
team in advent health north pinellas
you've been a source of strain for
patients in the icu during this pandemic
and i just want to let you know the work
you do
is nothing short of remarkable
[Music]
here we come tampa for super bowl 55.
[Music]
just finishing up all the packing and
the last thing in is my titans jersey
on my way to texas bay
man this is crazy
we getting ready to walk into the game
there we go
is it like kc brisket here's brady's
pass
it's gronkowski
it warmed my heart to know
that people appreciate us during such a
hard time
i will never forget this i will hold it
in my memories forever this is something
that i will never forget
that will go down in history as being
one of the greatest moments and
opportunities that i've
ever received in life
why did they deserve it too you know boy
did they deserve it and i loved that the
first thing that the
the buccaneers owner edward glaser said
at the end of the game was
we're paying tribute to them yeah very
nice listen when the football season
started people weren't even sure there
would be a super bowl
so 268 games later there they are and
you're
so right if anybody should deserve to go
it's them yeah it's a reminder for all
of us that there is a future and
eventually we'll all get to do that and
with their hard work more of us will
yeah but that was a great thank you
and and we can't say thank you enough
for everything they've done
thank you say it thank you that'll do it
for us we'll see you tomorrow right here
on the table